this South African Pangolin is nicknamed
bumper he was confiscated during an
undercover operation and is one of many
brought to vet Debbie English so a lot
of people first of all don't know they
exist and they don't really understand
how endangered these little animals are
by the time they get to this Clinic the
pangolins are in desperate need of
medical treatment more often than not
they are emaciated dehydrated and most
of them have pneumonia when we when we
receive them the animals are kept in
appalling conditions before they're
traded on the black market they're left
in car boots bags and plastic drums for
days or even weeks
one Pangolin can fetch up to 15 000 US
Dollars their meat and scales which are
made of keratin are used in traditional
African and Asian medicine it's the most
traded of the illegal wildlife animals
currently and that's where it's taken
over from the Rhinos in a big way this
undercover agent for the African
Pangolin working group poses as a buyer
and once we've put the deal together
we'll set up a time and location where
we do the transaction and this is where
the sting operation will go down
Wildlife traffickers face up to 10 years
in prison in South Africa the pangolins
are confiscated and taken to a
rehabilitation center at a secret
location it takes a long time medically
to get them back into a position where
we can release them so some animals are
here for a month and then some nearly a
year it's a labor-intensive process the
challenge with rehabilitating these
animals is not just the enormous cost
that's involved but it's also the time
alignments required South African
pangolins won't eat in captivity and so
they need to forage for food for up to
six hours a day Emma Diaga has a team of
staff and volunteers and while getting
the back into the wild is the ultimate
goal conservationists say it's not
enough in every one that we save and the
time that we save that hundreds and
thousands of being poached in that time
we're not talking a matter of 10 years
they'll be extinct we're talking a year
they are shy and secretive they don't
hurt anybody but yet we're destroying
them the clinic receives no Government
funding the undercover agent also works
for free it's for each and every person
every citizen every person to actually
protect the wildlife because we are
protecting it not for ourselves but for
our future Generations
as for bumper he's been released back
into the wild one of the few success
stories in this campaign to save the
Pangolin Emily anguin Al Jazeera tzaneen
South Africa